now we focus on the Democratic candidate
and another close Senate races when in
Pennsylvania Lieutenant Governor John
fetterman just gave his first in-person
on-camera interview since having a
stroke five months ago fetterman showed
NBC News how he uses closed captioning
to read questions in real time to
overcome the physical effects of his
stroke Robert Costa has the latest on
this story
can voters trust that you will be able
to do this job on day one
yeah of course in a recent interview
with NBC News which aired yesterday
Pennsylvania's Democratic Senate nominee
John fetterman was seen using a closed
captioning device as he has in some
settings since his stroke in May that
auditory processing where I'll hear
someone speaking but sometimes they'll
be able to be precise on what exactly
that they're saying I use captioning the
interview was the latest prism into the
Pennsylvania Lieutenant Governor's
recovery process which has become a
political Target in one of the nation's
key Senate races with Republican mehmed
Oz pressing fetterman to disclose more
about his health I'm calling on John
fetterman veterans campaign has
disclosed his use of the captioning
technology several times since he began
his post-stroke media interviews I feel
like we have been very transparent in a
lot of different ways when our doctor
has already given a letter saying that
I'm able to serve and to be running I
mean respectfully that letter from your
position that was six months ago don't
voters deserve to know your status now
being on in front of thousands and
thousands of people and having
interviews and getting around all across
Pennsylvania that gives everybody and
the voters decide you know if they think
that it's it's really the issue after
the interview aired Tuesday night
fetterman's campaign said in a statement
John is healthy and he also still has a
lingering auditory processing issue that
is doctors expect will go away adding
he's been transparent in talking openly
about his health while also showing
voters how this closed caption
technology helps him communicate more
effectively All Eyes now turn to the
October 25th debate between fetterman
and oz in Harrisburg which will be the
one debate in the race several National
Democratic strategists told CBS news
last night that fetterman's recovery
will be a variable on that stage and for
the rest of the race but they're
confident that alarm over the future of
abortion rights and questions over Oz's
ties to Trump could lift fetterman's
chances in the swing Suburban areas
around Philadelphia and Pittsburgh
President Biden will wait in soon
hosting a fundraiser for fetterman next
week in Philadelphia Tony
Bob Costa for us Bob thank you very much